this is clearly an attempt to say to
Iran and hisbah as the president himself
has said don't get involved placing Iran
and hisbah in before quite a dilemma in
a certain sense because they've been
talking in recent years now for what
they call the unification of the Arenas
or unification of the fronts which is
supposed to represent this notion of a
kind of United group of islamist uh
paramilitary movements behind Iran under
Iran's leadership directed against
Israel and if Israel now does go into
Gaza in a major way and Iran then does
not intervene they will look somewhat
weakened in a middle eastern context
having not sort of backed up a great
deal of rhetoric in recent years at the
same time with the USS General Ford
there Gerald Ford there in the
Mediterranean Iran would be taking the
real chance of tussling with United
States military response